Namaste what's up everyone we're about
to play something I think if anyone is
most excited about it's probably you rob
we're play
GTA five on PC today it's been a long
time past two and uh yeah it's been it's
been a while but here we go we're
rocking right now we're in we had a um
we had to postpone the stream about half
an hour because there was a kind of day
one patch update which was unexpected
but here we are I think it's quite
expected I I expected to see some issues
with maybe um downloading I figured
their servers would be getting slammed I
mean it is what it's 5:00 p.m. now it
went live at 400 p.m. today so this is a
mere hour old and I you know you expect
a few issues like that but
we're think so yeah we
haven't really even optim optimized as
much as we'd like you might be able to
see some screen tearing but we've
definitely seen some we'll have to just
kind of deal with it for
now um but yeah I am playing with mouse
and keyboard
here see if I can switch to first person
actually I really wanted to so let's
actually yeah's we can go through
through some of the settings here
keyboard
mouse
oops so yeah obviously a lot of in-depth
um settings here for
mouse
cool so yeah you can you know obviously
if you're flying in a plane or a
helicopter you can adjust those
accordingly I mean it's got to be
completely different yeah and you you
haven't we haven't had time to like test
out any of this stuff so we might have
to come back in here and kind of yeah I
just quickly want to see go through the
ropes yeah we'll come back to this I
just wanted to see so V is camera okay
cool that is all I wanted to know we'll
go back oh CU you're planing on getting
some sweet shots are I mean this feels
great this is uh first person here shoot
at his
feet get out of there dance dance
boy get in there I not
hesitate so I'm sure you can even you
know get even further customization as
far as like do I want to aim down sights
cuz right now I'm using the middle Mouse
click on the scroll to do that okay
whoops phone looks good yeah look at
that it doesn't look like that I saw you
save the number console it's all shiny
there's some serious Bloom going on oh
yeah real
hot speaking of
Boom not what I said I know I tried all
right you going to do this here we
go show me the money slow and steady get
back slow and steady you mean it okay so
it's never mind it's not click it's
scroll it's for uh aim down
sides I hold the left button sorry sorry
right button on the mouse and then
scroll
cool here for us all to enjoy on how so
I'm working on gra graphs comparison
right now and uh this is one of those
things where I've seen and played this
intro so many times man um also for
anyone watching us live um I do have a
PC open I can look at comments so if you
guys have anything specific you want to
ask or have us do go ahead and throw it
in the comments um sometimes if you put
comment before your or question before
your comment or big Q I can see it
easier uh so go ahead and do that if you
have anything you want to
ask you didn't have to do that let's get
going yeah and um grieving later I do
know I mean I have to play in order to
kind of like experiment open world you
have to get through like the first two
missions so that's this one and then the
one with Franklin
so qes take cover interesting we did
turn off vsync but I think it's
something else that's causing the
tearing right now
yeah um we haven't had time to get into
all the settings yet obviously we're
going to have to mess with that at some
pointz Prett
glaring um what's the settings of the PC
we're using Rob uh I believe this is a 7
GTS
760 that's right don't be an idiot
and I have I believe uh I mean I yeah
again I only got to kind of change
settings for
like a minute a minute but um believe
right now we're on like fairly normal
settings but um there's plenty else to
like kind of change up it looks
great um I think that was to be expected
besides the tearing I
think forward um how long does it take
you to download this is a big uh what is
it 60 gigs the preload wasn't too bad um
we did that earlier today that that took
probably like 30 40 minutes oh it's
nothing but um this patch update was
what took a while that's took um and
that could just be the fact that
everyone's trying to do that right now
and maybe their servers were overloaded
or something like that I don't know um I
you're probably looking at like a couple
hours especially now I mean I would
expect if you did it right at 4:30 when
this thing went live you might have
gotten early in the queue but right
around now I feel like when people are
coming home from work and they have
they're all they're all going to start
downloading it at once so I think it's
really going to start start adding up
pretty soon yeah man first person really
feels
good mouse and
keyboard feel like you have more I mean
there's just no denying most people feel
much more
accurate with the mouse so the the other
issue though is that like you know know
there is auto lock and there and there
is that online so regardless of like how
you feel first person whether it's
better or not like I don't know it's
going be interesting to see like if
people really going to be rocking it uh
as far as online goes um just because
there is the like ability to auto lock
auto aim excuse
me I would always think I think auto aim
was something that um was just so
helpful on Console because of the way it
aimed but if you have a preference I
mean I would always not I would like to
not do that and and have the ability to
just kind of enjoy it the way it is I
mean I this feels really great though I
mean
like this is like this first impression
right now I
mean I mean you're mowing them down yeah
it's like it's working
out first driving this is yeah first
driving what took you so long shut the
[__] up and try you see that [__]
[__] put that bitch's face against
the glass we're gonna play the opening
sequence oh man it looks good we're
going to play the opening sequence but I
do think at some point we're going to
get into the editor and see if we can
make something today yeah something
small so yeah once I get to open world I
wanted to show off like I don't know
maybe I was considering maybe doing like
a custom um because you can of course
customize your radio but I I don't think
that will be worth showing but yeah I
mean at the end of the stream I
definitely want to like kind of have
like a final 15 second
video uh that we've messed around within
um editor but yeah it's just getting to
like the open world point at this at
this moment in time we move quick the
train
we cops coming our way B ain't made this
car yet man I'll believe when I get eyes
on it give me credit for changing
cameras while you're while you're
driving that's you're on the wrong side
of it
oh hey
guys I'm wondering what like handbreak
is and
stuff [__] you
buddy
uhoh such a good way to get started in
this game uh do you think like this is
the kind of thing that's going to make
you play through the story one more time
play You' played through it twice now um
probably at least but there's like the
original time it came out and then first
person first person I only got like
halfway through and then I kind of
stopped uh once I realize I'm going to
do it again in PC but so the thing is is
one of the motives to play PC story is
there's the director mode part which you
can um play as other characters
um and a lot of these characters are
only unlockable through missions in the
story so completing the story 100% will
give you all the unlockable characters
in which is fine I'm cool with
that I'm interested in seeing um the
loading times between switching between
characters um that's going to take a
little bit of time because you don't get
to switch right away in this
mhm
M down you [__] [__] suckers
lovely
[__] oh
yeah [__] die all of
you definitely
a adult
stream hey you
hey
I mean we we all knew going into it that
it was going to look really good I would
say like still though on current gen it
also looked pretty pretty darn good like
there's nothing to me this isn't the
ultimate version there's just
nothing to me that looks so unbelievably
different that you just have to buy it
on PC I think you know it's the
additional features that are going to
make people want to buy it again 100%
yeah
and um you get a few things when you buy
the PC version I mean yeah unless you
know obviously running like a like if
you have a really high on rig you're
obviously you're getting 60
frames yeah it's going to look much
better draw distances are are improved
um there is that but if you have just
like a
standard PC package yeah you're you're
really getting the the video editor in
my opinion video editor is huge like
that is if you really like to make
videos which I do and a lot of people do
and now you can just make pretty awesome
things like I forgot like this director
mode like you can play as any character
in the game and you can I forgot I I
didn't realize this um is you can have
them say lines as well like kind of like
a standard dialogue package so you can
really create like pretty pretty awesome
scenes and we've already seen a little
bit of that there was a video released
earlier today of um I think it was
Trevor
jogging um and it looked really really
good and it got all sorts of
perspectives from various people just um
pedestrians on the street it can get
birds and dogs on the street it can it
can get it from any perspective of
anything within that block radius it's
right some really amazing opportunities
for Creative people I'm really
interested to see what the community is
going to make with it oh yeah if that's
our standard for goodness no wonder this
country's screwed
and what about
you what about
me
hey I'm just going to skip
this come on we're not here for that
come
on damn this [__] must got the baby
dick yeah so another thing that's huge
is like even doing that if you notice
how I could
like it's hard to
track motion while walking M on a
controller like here I can I can simply
just like walk
straight without fighting the The View
like on say like a console
sticky [__] only
child oh you falling hard with the drop
toop huh I might just be whatever [__]
it ain't going to make what about your
initial driving did it feel any
different oh it's like that [__] yeah
it Ian it's it's still getting used to I
mean like I was always afraid of like
the a andd um Keys being an issue
like space of ours it's pretty good
you're doing like more work with I I
wonder if you can even I'm sure you can
change like how you want the view um on
your mouse to feel like do you want it
to snap back like on a controller uh
currently it's
not there's more options so it's just
about customizing it to what you want
yeah like driving always feels better on
controller
my so what are we running the game at
right
now uh this is
1080p um I mean I I'll have to open up
settings again I want to get again I
want to get to open world and then
really start messing with
it but as far as I remember I kind of
just went through and and made most
things high or normal filing [__] um
right now it's doing all right I think
it's running fine earlier there's some
screen tearing um I'm not seeing much
right
now like I don't know I don't know if I
like
keyboard I mean it's it's bearable how
do you um I assume you have a gun right
now no I don't not here I you can how
you pull out a weapon while driving um
because that was always for me like
shooting while driving was always pretty
tough um nice because you're basically
putting both your pointer finger and
your middle finger on to have like both
bumper and triggers so yeah and you
could and you could they did that later
for uh current gen so you can CH you can
change that in settings depending on
what yeah suits you yeah it was it was
um that was kind of a pain yeah now
you're right I'm curious to know how a
lot of these controls work
on keyboard yeah for shooting I mean
yeah you'd have to hold down some some
button in order to right what was so
frustrating about shooting was um
wherever you were shooting is basically
where you were driving yeah and it could
easily trip you up so I assume it's
probably similar so I can already tell
you what it is it's it's going to be
it's right on the um it's right Mouse
button okay is going to be aim at least
I can tell you that much can you aim and
drive all right aim that middle finger
and drive around
just pissed off constantly
whoa you're doing it all in first
person but then again like certain
things feel pretty good like first
person um with the mouse while driving
feels pretty good cuz again it's always
like you're you're you're always
fighting the um the view in on a console
controller like here you just you got
complete freedom to look oh [__] the one
time be cool fool we got the paperwork
whatever you explain that [__]
whatever lose him L's the fuzz eight no
thing so let's look behind
see no
no like cop cop experimenting how do I
look
behind will you look in your rearview
mirror look your rearview mirror you
can't see in it it's all blurry oh it is
C I thought it going
see your review mirror is a
lie hey excuse
me I just feel
like I'm seeing a lot of things for the
first time but a lot of that's probably
just because I'm looking for differences
I'm looking at all the gauges on the car
and everything yeah but everything looks
real crisp and real clear
change the radio so I would love to but
I'm trying to think what would that
be okay no that's his P so cap locks is
his power
okay ability whatever alt alt okay so
there we'll get to that later so there
how switch people yeah so how you switch
people is also how you
um use the uh recording
video recorder oh
sorry
whoops you want to start
recording no I'll do it later I I'll do
open world first
okay look like I'm just curious look
behind to C duck is X that was like
using your Hydraulics use x oh here we
go so there's a new radio station and it
is
stations look
cool Bingo the uh the lab is that your
favorite this is the new station they
add they add a whole brand new uh radio
station uh I don't know if's my favorite
I don't know I have CL we're to figure
it out what's your favorite now it was
um classic rock oh no no my favorites
are space 1032 baby and uh low down are
my favorites it's funny like how much
detail goes into all the radio stations
too well you like even the other day I
didn't know I think uh I forget if it's
fly low but there's somewhere where you
know hell buris a comedian he's like it
he's he's in one of the radio stations
like I think he's like a on scene like
reporter or something like that someone
was telling me for I I never I only
listened to space 1032 so I never even
know like knew that type of you're
always listening to the same radio
station I just just Lov some of the
songs on it too much but the the um
booty Collins is like the DJ on that and
he is a famous bass player in like
Parliament here we
go you're broke it's SP 1032
Baby M baby you are a racist and I don't
like you and I will not sell you this
card I will not you make my skin crawl
you Neo-Nazi you are all the same you're
disgusting This Racist insulted me hey
what's up boo Who you calling a [__] no
no I'm not calling nobody a [__] wait
what the [__] I
mean that's not cool man I don't see
interaction Fu right and you better keep
it right cuz this man right here he's an
international business man a
multiculturalist that I could not have
said better
myself but seriously maybe he's there's
a lot of BL going on here but I don't
think that he is man enough for a car
like this wait wait a second
this guy right here him get him a Hy
that's a real man's car I think you are
right Lamar you get a tax rebate I money
Bloom is a trick used to help hide rough
edges um sometimes in P yeah hey s I'm
out like increase the bloom so it looks
super nice
yeah hope you like your car brought it
back Nice condition flip
that okay I'm almost there I have to go
to the house now yeah get in your whip
and that's it then we can really Anker
around get in
Lamar this jump change how I'm going to
knock a bad grown in the beginning he
talks about your y ass
haircut this the best part it is part
she grown yeah she grown into a [__]
idiot there's no um there's no
transferring or anything like that for
the game if you want to play it on PC
transferring with what um your your
character anything like that yeah so you
can transfer your character um and keep
so if I had I have Xbox one I can trans
what about PS3 yeah any console you play
your game on for online you can transfer
your character and still keep your
character on whatever console you're
playing so basically it just duplicates
whatever you got for online and um you
can just move that over the PC and play
PC so essentially then at that point you
have two different characters who are at
the same starting ground so if you play
PC you'll be working on just a PC
character okay so it'll transfer it but
then you can't go back and forth It's
not cross save or anything like that
transferred over and then that's it
right it's not like a cloud safe type
thing at least you don't lose
everything what
right okay cool so
honey y'all telling me Oh he here we
living on top of each other and it ain't
right
sh get on out of here funny okay baby
I'll see you what the thing every family
character in this
entire game
is disappointing yeah in the sense that
their character is so so difficult to be
around I like everyone sucks get me out
of here no one's nice no one's enjoyable
let me just take out my family problems
on some some people downtown I mean
everyone typically agree like all the
people yeah of all the characters and
all their shitty lives Michael's got it
the worst which is funny he's like kids
yeah he's got like I don't know you
think like the nicest
lifestyle but he's
just he's just miserable yeah just shows
money can't buy you happiness unless it
buys you another copy of
GTA
PC all right
so we're kind of in a world right now
which is a good point so I want to get
downtown and mess around with like
population density and see sounds good
I'd like to test the limits of what this
is capable of sure and again yeah we're
running on us uh GTS GTX uh 760
how do I so how do I hang them up hang
up on
Franklin you answered it damn it he
enter again maybe that hangs up oh so
it's right uh Mouse button
okay it looks like you're adapting
pretty
well yeah get some different camera
angles on
there it'll work
out
like my like
Horn uh S modeus smac Mode is R
great now you know how to get
out shut up
Mary whatever okay put on town do you
get
um when you transfer do you get any
money
so if I think they had because they
delayed PC version they had like a bonus
that's right you get a big bonus I think
it's wasn't it like getting really high
like
1.4 s like that total but then it like
Dives up to like online and then single
player that's right who wants money in
single player I don't understand no one
does no one
Rockstar can you hit a few more people
sure want to see what it looks like like
this yes
like one star what tell the limits of
blood splatter in this
world cool I want well now I have a star
Army be fine I'll be
right okay so let's see there's people
in front of us mhm
I don't want a cop to show up right when
I'm doing settings I just pause the game
never
mind let's do that
one okay so settings
MH uh uh uh uh uh so it's maxed out
population density
already
variety the way I like my
people
diverse motion blur
strength sounds awful I don't know how
much motion blur you want on
there after
Shadows we I mean I don't know if I
crank it up I will have to restart so
I'm not going to mess with it too much
let's see if this I get away with
this you see any diversity in these
people here get out
cool get out and see how diverse these
people are I don't if's if you any how
about
you oh no I just looking at me
what get right up in their domes come on
I haven't seen any other girl with
pigtails oops sorry you've upset
everyone so I'm curious to know what it
would look like
oops no
okay if we crank this
really imagine I guess you we'd have to
drive around a bit in order to take
effect yeah look at that there's like no
one
out did you turn it all the way down
yeah what about the diversity and that
as well all
right this is like what regular America
looks
like okay let's try it all the way up
again just
curious
what's distance
scaling yeah more groups
there annoying this CL
yeah there's more people you can
tell does it look
any roll does it look any more populated
than the console version like to me it
looks pretty similar I wouldn't say it
looks yeah I I don't know I mean more
populated it looks just about the same
yeah I mean I was just playing Xbox one
earlier
like it looks it looks about the
same lost here well yeah uh why don't we
mess around with video editor do
it let's get the cops off off the of us
excuse me and then we'll uh make a
little scene or something or we actually
could even just go check out director
mode should we do that yep
okay so I want to make a movie I want to
be a movie
star you want to be a star don't you Rob
so you got
kid um where do you go for director
mode wasn't it saying in the Rockstar
editor does it bring up director
mode no I mean I believe it
was
people are asking about the load times
we haven't changed characters yet so
it's it's hard to tell like how long
it's going to take in between characters
or um when there's a cut scene
everything so far has been pretty smooth
from the cutcenes that we've been
watching even like yeah we don't know
much about character switching mode as
far as loading times but even uh like
initial uh loading was fairly
quick um quicker I would say then
console well unless I I don't want to
waste much time trying to find this
thing well we can check
out let's just do this for now so I'm
going to record a
scene so I see the left there I can
either start recording or turn on Action
Replay so I'm going to do I'm going to
turn it on start recording cuz there's
bunch of cops are about to come after
you so again if you're ever going to
record you have to be in third person
could you hit a few people uh duh thank
you oh he was on the Ben I think he
survived okay so let's do this uh on
hold
on sorry I'm not used to this yet okay
um save so I whatever just happened last
30 seconds you being shot that's
fine cool with it that's okay so let's
see this return to enter the
editor oh here's D
mode
okay um so I just going to create one
here
fine add a clip here's our last
clip let's edit
it
yes now you've seen this a little bit
before yeah and it was really easy to
pick up uh I I only had about like an
hour or two with it and by like the end
of it I was like I had made like two
three
videos
um let's see so let's play our clip here
mhm been
rended this is the clip it's like we
were
there this when I told you to hit people
right it didn't work
out you got it no
problem my
Whip and that guy got crushed so I think
after reviewing this clip I think a good
part of the story was the guy who was on
the bench yeah I agree so let's see what
his view was like
what was life from his perspective
what's really interesting is I was
actually you when I was messing around
with this
um before for the preview I forgot like
using the mouse is so much easier I was
using the controller for some reason I
thought that was just for me it was
easier but like Mouse you can get really
fine so let's see here
um yeah you can scrub it like right down
to the exact millisecond that you want
no okay so I'm going to do um I kind of
forgot so marker
here and I want to change this
camera so I'm going to I can do free
camera right oops oh so here are
um take me through this cuz I haven't
seen any of this before sure so again
it's like imagine there's a bubble
around my character so whe whatever is
in the bubble I can essentially go to or
um go to as and change the camera to
like their perspective their perspective
or just track whatever they're doing and
just basically get uh crazy can you get
that girl in
pink see her right in front and she like
doesn't notice you yet but she's going
to let's see is it just pop to them one
at a time or can you select her I'm
gonna try I'm still pretty new to this
let's see now type that's stupid okay no
got Target move with
Target so I want you
to see of course it I mean it's giving
me numbers so I
can't okay these are like generic
cinematic options look at car move with
Target
six oh that's right edit camera okay
who I'm going to move I'm use the
controller here cuz this was easier for
me to yeah get up get up all up in in
his face I want see it I want to see his
face zoom
in he's like what about he's not even
looking out the
window where is he going like I love my
steering wheel where is his right hand
can you get in the car can you like be
in the driver's seat next to
him I don't think
so get
really
perfect that's the
perspective that's the shot we want
that's it now I want to
change
play okay so we want that guy we want
want this
guy this is back to the beginning of
your clip
right replaying it are we so I I made
this camera basically right you made
the
No No that's right
okay
you obviously change
drunk do
drunk intensity of that do intense all
the
way crazy Hammer drunk yeah look at that
oh
it's that's what it's like when we drive
did it keep
it it didn't save it
cuz I changed the camera by accident
let's see here no it still says junk
10 oh there she is she's five I guess
all right that's what we
want oh she's so
oh did she
Dodge you got her you got her okay
okay but at this point I want the camera
to yeah I mean I wish I was like quicker
with this stuff so I apologize toone
watching free camera I want to move
to that
dude all right so what are you changing
right now I'm trying
to let's see here it's moving with
Target what what would you say you're
trying to
do so I think it's moving
to goinging a lot here
uhhuh so that shot right there is no
good because I have no idea what I'm
looking
at I need more action in this
shot oh there's some
action I believe that's bench guy bench
guy so you can even I believe like start
off with like a preset camera and then
you can like change with that or like
kind of alter this
one so I
can go upside down or something like
that I think like you could probably do
a pretty slick Michael Bay can you um
animate the camera and actually have it
Circle upside down right can you do that
absolutely oh
W that's pretty cool
yeah let's have the camera do like a
security camera let's have the camera do
a full
circle okay let's see
here
oops you have almost quit this several
times we're going to make this
clip so I'm going to from here here I
want it to
follow now I'll start so from
here and then when it get
here camera so I want it to end
up go on I want it to move around shoot
and how long can the clips be here like
what's your max can you make a full
movie that's like 20 minutes long
they're like broken up in
um they're broken up in 30 second can
you make a screenshot out of that looks
pretty good we're not doing screenshots
yet so hot so
hot
oh
no oh
no so this what I'm going to do here is
okay remember correct correctly is nope
I found
it is you need
to
what sorry here well tell me what you're
doing first I'm trying you trying to do
I'm trying to basically have this uh
camera move uhhuh and not uh
um not cut to the next camera but follow
it okay do you think like because you
just have so many options at this stage
is just kind of hard to figure out what
you're actually trying to accomplish
yeah I'm not going to spend much more
time I we'll we'll throw some like
effects on it so we can get an idea of
like so you can do all this different
stuff it's like
Instagram Touch of Evil Normandy that's
great so like World War II
like kind of
burned oh could you lower the speed I'd
like to see it a little bit
slowmo not that much that's really slow
and is that just for that marker or is
that for your entire clip it's for the
marker right so if you if you can tell
here right I can see where it's getting
slow-mo by the
arrows like a glove now I want it to be
slow when he's like flipping right here
yeah like that's when it's good this
camera and then the other marker it can
actually be regular speed cuz like
nothing's happening
cool does the audio get slow mode too is
like all the girls like yeah
no exactly what about the radio uh well
I can always go if I wanted to keep the
song the same I can go back cuz radio is
separate right right so I could cut out
radio here and then I could put in my
song that do get slow I have to do that
later
um so say we'll call it here whatever
the hell this video is right here oh see
him it's cap shot it's
brilliant we can change
this yeah let's do back or right yeah
that's good we haven't had a wheel shot
in a while do a little oh yeah handheld
that sounds great all right so I can
even change the camera a little bit more
here
oh I we'll leave it
there I feel like you could spend all
goddamn day on
this
a
bam
cool save I keep doing it um you love to
quit well just I want to go back here we
go Okay cool so so we can call it there
all right all right now let's add some
music so I'm going to save this yeah um
now I'm going to go
back timeline so yeah if I again it's 30
second Clips uh this was what we used
the action replay so it just recorded
like an event it recorded what happened
um and that was 30 seconds right um if I
were to let it running it would just
break them up into 30 second clips and
then I would have to pull from like my
selection back here okay so I would go
like back here I go add clip here is
where um so add your radio track radio
track so uh any songs you have in mind
uh let's get to the new radio station
new radio station so the lab
Lab anything here well I don't really
know any of these currency and Freddy
Gibbs what you looking sounds good oh
you might not see it because it's it's
currency with a dollar sign for the S uh
Fetti is the first I assume it means fun
Fetti which is my favorite type of cake
so that must be what this is
about so yeah and I can also start from
anywhere in the song
oops uh where's my timeline
again maybe you have to go back to oh
there you go there you go
Okay cool so that's there um we want
like song for sure based
on my knowledge of the fety
song so let's
trim
nope God it's like looking
at Final Cut
Pro the new
one I move I don't like when things
snap I'll tell you where I want the clip
to go
yeah you don't know
me so we'll start there 11 seconds in we
can go even more this is actually so
true I think let's just put it in
there this is what happens when you get
people who edit video for a living to
edit a clip for this game is that it's
way too
long um so let's just uh
export I'm going save it just
case do some
low actually cut and print I'm not even
going to export it because I think
that's going to take some
time here here's a
preview see if this
works oh it's beautiful can you hear uh
music yeah there is
it's everything I thought it would be
right here
and oh smash side shot
slowmo and then World War II status and
then he just pulls
away with an Instagram
filter great she's running cool well
that's it it's [__] beautiful it's
the most beautiful video you ever made
Rob and that's saying something about
being very your skill as a video editor
I've never seen anything that nice ah
thank you well I think what that really
says is just what this is capable of
yeah um and it's not something that I
think is going to happen super fast I
think you're going to have to spend some
time with it but I do think it's looks
pretty exciting yeah something you'll
have to spend a lot more time with
probably yeah and I think like for me
like and probably most a lot of people
is um you know just like exporting like
this the camera angle and that's about
it like you wouldn't want to throw in so
many effects like in game unless you're
trying to go right from in game to
YouTube as opposed to like bringing into
your eding system like whatever you got
to get more like precise that's what I'm
saying all right well why don't you um
get in first person and murder a bunch
of people and then we'll call it a day
cool I'd like to see the variety of
pedestrians that we murder and see if we
have any issues with like frame rate or
anything else like that while we're
playing let's go like a area and try
that
out excuse me look like a good place to
start a
fight yeah I don't like I don't like any
of these
people
what do you got you have anything on you
or you got to not
here I got nothing just
my I mean it's something what I'm just
staring at
you come on why you don't just idly
watch people get
murdered jerk you have to interfere
oh holy hell EO
please
tackle
tackle oh oh oh a
blimp it was such a beautiful
day officer oh perfect you're not going
to believe what just happened so steal
the car hey
guys
oh did you check the glove box sometimes
cops keep drugs in don't you get like a
uh a
umpp me off don't you get like a uh
shotgun whenever you get into
like oh what's like just said you were
unarmed I wonder if I get out I have a
weapon that would be
nice your Park
here parallel park
it yeah I thought so all right select
it
use
that use that Mouse aim he's not dead
yet finish him you got it oh oh that's
weird that an ankle shot was what killed
him
oh ankle
shot some camera Shake I'm not here get
in X to duck done um tap X about
great great just wanted to see just
wanted to
see go to the
beach what the oh still I'm going to try
to steal oh my God look at my car well
it's not your car you stole that that's
a police car no it's mine now fair
enough though oh this is not what I
wanted oh you died
BL you're going to lose your probably
going lose your
shotgun well I mean it's just a quick
Glimpse but that's that's pretty much
what you're getting I wouldn't say it's
like just the most incredibly different
visually looking game but you're getting
um a
sweet editor option and um I mean like
the ability with that just seems like
Limitless whatever you can do yeah I
mean there's so much more to that uh as
you you could see um you could easily
Just Lose Yourself with so many
different options and camera I you did I
kind of did um but yeah that's it I mean
obviously yeah depending on your PC and
how uh it runs uh you could have a
completely different experience than us
but it ran fine with us I would say
obviously there's some tearing that
we're getting that I don't like too much
but um we need to mess around with the
settings we literally downloaded it and
just started it immediately as is so um
I'm sure there's a lot of options that
there yet to be messed with with but
that is GTA 5 on PC so far um currently
our downloading time wasn't very much it
was an hour for the patch once we got
the actual download and that's only
because there's so many people in the
queue so um obviously like a lot of
people are slamming the servers right
now but uh it sounds like it's it's
working and you can get in right now and
that's it give it a whirl oh yeah let's
see what you can make with your video
you think you you do so much better than
Rob probably you think you're so good
probably do it it's good it's good stuff
all right well thanks for joining us and
we'll be making some cool stuff with
that video editor soon see you guys bye
bye